Giant robot.
Steven universe.
It's an adventure show about a boy with
superpowers derived from an interstellar
gemstone in his belly,
but in many ways it's also a coming of
age story about a young man growing up
and trying to find his place in the room.
Some of your weapon.
Calm down, Steven, breathe.
Oh,
it was really close to that time.
Coming of age. Narratives for boys
usually involve in education, in sex,
sports,
hunting or fighting.
Yeah.
These activities are framed as a sort of
rite of passage in stories set in Scifi
fantasy or superhero genre is combat
is almost always the mechanism through
which young men must
prove their worthiness.
This is usually not framed as outright
aggression on the heroes part.
What is it
instead?
Justified as the ability to fight back.
There are accompanying characteristics
like wit, determination,
cleverness or confidence,
but learning how to be tough and
proficient in dealing out violence is
consistently framed as a necessary
okay
boys to complete their journey
into manhood. As the series begins,
Steven Universe appears to be following
in the footsteps of these well-worn
conventions.
Steven wants his own gym powered weapon
to help fight off monsters like the
other crystal gems.
But when he finally
does Chondra his weapon,
yeah,
it isn't a weapon,
Steven,
and this is where the series begins to
depart from classic genre expectations.
Rather than being disappointed and not
getting an offensive or aggressive skill.
Steven wholeheartedly embraces
his new defensive superpower.
I'll get a shoe
this way.
The show continues.
It's a version of boy hero tropes.
When we find out that Stephen is a healer,
what do you see without my glasses?
Did I heal your eyes?
But how
his mother had healing tears,
whereas Steven has
who sparks?
I don't have healing tears.
Yeah, maybe little gross,
but when you think about it,
that essentially means that
Steven possesses healing
kisses, healing, affection.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's something new and exciting.
Okay,
you should be better now.
So Steven's a healer and his Jim power
is centered around shielding others from
harm. Now that's especially interesting
because in many fantasy stories and video
games, those were both considered
to be secondary or support skills.
Medics and other protective spell casters
have often been gendered roles are
roles that have been filled by women
who stand back and supplement the other
warrior classes who have
traditionally been myth.
This convention has begun to change in
recent years, which is a really good sign,
but the gendering of these types of roles
still remains a pervasive pattern in
media giving these kinds of support
powers to the male protagonist.
He's a fun if pretty
straight forward in version,
but I'd argue that Steven
has another superpower,
something that's even more important and
even more fundamental to his character
and to the show's values as a
whole. You see, Steven is in Papic.
You might even say he's super empathic.
Steven, your mother had Hayden
tears flowed from my gym.
She felt real love for those around her.
She felt real sorrow when they were hot.
You have the rose quartz damn.
Now I know that power is in youtube.
Empathy is the ability to understand
and share the feelings or emotions of
another person, but empathy is not
just feeling bad for someone else.
It's actually feeling what they feel
and that's an important distinction.
It's what separates sympathy from empathy,
spirits, sugar, so it's called,
I can feel it.
It's hurting and obsess.
Wait, how do you know? I don't,
but I could just feel it.
She was yelling and she was really
freaked out as season one begins.
The show's structure seems to be following
a fairly standard monster of the week
adventure show formula.
Right Ben?
In episode 23 which is appropriately
titled Monster Buddies,
we start to get the sense that this
is not just a show about going on fun
adventures and fighting baddies like a
lot of other shows in the same genre tend
to be at the beginning of that episode.
We see the gems fighting a monster
just like they have many times before.
One more attached to it. This time
Stephen reacts a little differently.
Did you see it? No. Okay. Let's
rewind it and watch it again.
Okay, so notice that the creatures arm
is damaged during the season calendar.
Seeing
this, Steven expresses for her
wellbeing while grabbing at his own arm.
Essentially Stephen is
super sensitive to others.
He possesses the capacity to vicariously
experience other people's feelings.
When someone else is hurting,
Steven hurts.
He feels their pain as if it were his own.
This kind of super sensitivity
is especially rare for
boy heroes because in our
culture,
emotional intuition is still
stereotypically associated
with women and as such,
media often frames.
It is overly sensitive girl stuff,
but on this show, things
work very differently. Well,
I think you're pretty
great in this universe.
It's common for male characters to act
in carrying an emotionally sensitive way.
You can watch my full episode
about that right here.
Later, Steven makes friends with
another monster and names her sentence
speed.
At first,
they're both afraid of each other,
but remember from my last video that
being afraid is not a negative trait on
this show
and Steven's fear is reasonable.
The monster is indeed dangerous,
but Steven is resolute in his conviction
that monsters are not all bad,
that there is still good in them.
It looks so scary. Oh, hi.
It's okay. Hello. Please
don't be scared of me. See,
I'm not going to hurt you
now. Critically, Stephen's belief that
his new monster buddy can be redeemed.
It's not framed by the show
is childish idealism. Instead,
it's looked upon as
honorable and commendable.
You don't need to fight.
This isn't new.
You're not amongst already more.
You're more than that.
The larger lore of this universe also
works to validate Steven's empathetic
convictions.
Recall that the crystal gems all have
extra terrestrial superpowers because of
their gemstones in the episode ocean gym,
we learned that all the monsters are
heroes have been fighting each week are
actually gems themselves or more
accurately. They once were gems,
but they've been,
huh?
I can't believe lapis would do this.
Jim shouldn't fight each other.
We're always fighting.
Chems actually what? Oh,
how do I put this?
All gyms aren't necessarily good.
They're all those monsters.
We've got used to be just like
acid, right, for all, yes,
but they've become corrupted and broken.
We have to take care of them.
Do contain them.
It's the best we can do for them for now.
This also illustrates one of
the core values of the show,
which is the belief in the possibility
of transformative redemption.
The truth is, rose, I tried to use
her powers to save these months just too,
but she was never able to heal them.
Never. But if she
couldn't do it, who knows?
Maybe when you have better
control of your powers,
you might help them in ways even
your mother couldn't even this one.
I'll keep it safe
and Steven,
along with his supercharged empathy
are often the voice of that message.
Wow. Wait for me, centripetal,
I promise you, you up Sunday he sees
Daptiv possibility in
everyone and everything,
even when the much more experienced gems,
maybe a little skeptical for Steven.
No one is unworthy of compassion
or empathy, even monsters.
Steven, be careful. This just
happened. Maybe I can do something,
Jasper, it's okay. I'm here.
I just want to try and heal you.
It's uncommon to see this
kind of empathy on television,
especially when expressed
for the bad guys. Well,
it's true that most good guys in media
do demonstrate some empathy for their
friends,
their family and their allies.
Those feelings are very rarely
extended to their enemies.
And it's almost unheard of in
programming aimed at children,
which tends more than most to break
narratives down and just simplistic,
good versus evil,
easy to digest lesson.
Damn
in most animated shows,
the bad guys simply can't be reformed.
If you look at everything from say
duck tails to the Batman Universe,
you'll notice that the villains are
by and large framed as evil by nature.
Villainy is not just something they do.
Villainy is what they are.
Prisoner will stand.
So any attempt at rehabilitation
is ultimately doomed to fail.
And the belief in the possibility of
redemption is therefore often framed as
foolish or naive or worse,
something that can actually
endanger society itself.
But on Steven Universe,
things are more nuanced. Here.
The bad guys don't just do bad things
because they're intrinsically or
inherently evil.
They do bad things because of their
history and their circumstances. Now,
the bad guys are no less dangerous,
but it does mean they're always exists.
At least the possibility for redemption.
And that possibility is what guides
and shapes Steven's action. Yeah.
Wait,
let me turn this off.
Hey, how's it going? Can you hear me?
Are you in there somewhere?
And this brings us to the final
point I want to make in this video.
A critical part of Steven super
empathy is that it's always actionable.
The actionable part is key.
Not only does he feel for others,
oh, she's coming back. He
also does something about it.
Alright,
everyone be supportive.
Steven consistently intervenes to
deescalate and resolve conflicts.
I don't want to fight anymore.
I said Hi.
In the episode ocean gem,
we get to see Steven using all of his
superpowers to de escalate a potentially
cataclysmic situation.
He ends the fight and ultimately resolves
the conflict by talking it out with
the antagonist.
Lapis,
I'm coming up to see you.
Lapis. What are you
doing here, Steven? What?
I know, what are you
doing here? This thing,
the ocean.
This is crazy.
Can we work this out with Joe?
Should be friends.
Steven talks with her.
He listens to her and he treats
her with empathy and kindness.
I just want to go home.
In the end.
He even uses his healing powers to mend
her broken gym even after she's tried to
hurt him,
his friends and his family.
Thank you,
Steven.
Now it's not all Kumbaya in beach city.
The crystal gems are not pacifists.
Our heroes are often forced into battle,
but when that happens,
Stephen's still expresses his discomfort.
Even when he's under attack. By muting,
they're attacking the drought.
What do we do?
So win or lose,
the specter of violence and
confrontation weighs heavy on his heart.
Something doesn't feel right about
this. Then use the d pad. No,
it's just these things.
We can't just leave their gems out there.
They're going to form again later.
If I could just bundle them,
then they'd be saying, come
on. We've got to help them.
And of course there's tension and
discord among friends from time to time,
sometimes even leading to physical fights,
but on this show,
those issues are ultimately resolved
through means other than violence and
domination, often at the
insistence of Stephen himself.
So it was all my fault.
Ha.
You totally weren't even
trying to sync with my dancing.
You know how I danced by now.
Come on guys.
Please stop fighting.
Why don't you
admit it? I'm just in him. Ferris meals.
Amethyst please. No more.
I know you're upset,
but I can't bear to watch
you two already each other.
It's Steven's faith
in the possibility of redemptive
transformation that drives his efforts to
prevent fights.
You listen to me now.
You were talking about things that
you do not understand. Garnet,
stop please. It's not
worth it. We're done here.
Let's just go home.
Come on,
baby melon. We have to stop this.
It's staffing hearts you so help me.
I alone it didn't do anything.
Don't hurt it.
I accidentally let it out of its bubble,
but it didn't even try to hurt me.
It's not like the other monsters.
It's just scared and confused.
Everything that we've talked about in
this episode is extremely rare for boy
heroes on TV,
but it really shouldn't be.
The world could use a whole
lot more of Steven superpowers.
We need more role models for boys where
empathy and deescalation and diplomacy
are framed as brave and heroic behaviors.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
You get that much need to
counterpoint to a cynical worldview.
The good news is that unlike a
magical shield or healing saliva,
you don't need an interstellar gemstone
to practice empathetic behaviors. Now,
it may take us some time to learn
how to wield them effectively,
but we all have access to
those very human superpowers.
I hope you enjoyed this in
depth exploration of themes
and messages on Steven
Universe. If you'd like to see more
videos related to media and manhood,
you can help fund the pop culture
detective agency over on our Patriot page.
Yeah.